liebe kollegen sehr geehrte damen und
herren sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin
es ist die letzte sitzung des deutschen
bundestags vor der wahl
sie müssen weiter zur iaa und deswegen
lassen sie mich zu beginn seiner rede
noch ein paar sätze sagen ja es ist eine
epoche die zu ende geht sie haben vor 16
jahren ein land von rot-grün übernommen
mit rekordarbeitslosigkeit
rekordverschuldung mit einem
negativ-rekord beim wachstum und ich
erlebe heute ein land mit 45 millionen
erwerbstätigen mit 2,5 millionen weniger
arbeitslose mit chancen für junge
menschen bei ausbildung und
beschäftigung und ja das weingut
richtungsentscheidung
ich habe in verschiedenen funktionen
auch mit ihnen den letzten jahren
zusammen gearbeitet und gern
zusammengearbeitet nicht immer
konfliktfrei aber ich darf ausdrücklich
an dieser stelle sagen immer geprägt von
meinem höchsten respekt gegenüber ihnen
persönlich ihre haltung ihrem
amtsverständnis und ihrem dienst
gegenüber unserem land sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin die liebe angela danke
glückauf und gottes segen
[Applaus]
deutlicher als diese
richtungsentscheidung die ansteht in
deutschland hätte sie eigentlich nicht
werden können als durch die rede von
herrn korte sehr geehrter herr korte das
war doch keine rede zur lage und
situation in deutschland das war eine
reine bewerbungsrede für rot-rot-grün
nichts anderes steckt dahinter
unglaublich dass sie jetzt auf eine
antwort warten und olaf scholz die sind
noch nicht gegeben hat wir alle warten
darauf ob sie heute noch kommt erklärt
glauben sie eine zwischenfrage der
kollegin match
noch eine bewerbungsrede
die frage war zunächst ob sie die rede
und die frage erlaubt inzwischen merken
wenn es eine frage nicht und nicht an
urlaub stolzes gehören ja herr präsident
unserer geschäftsordnung sieht ja auch
zwischenbemerkungen vor in meinem fall
ist das er in der danksagung der kollege
dobrindt hat er ein video produziert
indem er weit vor rot-rot-grün zu warnen
und mich lässt dort auch auftreten und
zwar direkt nach arnold schwarzenegger
und zwar mit den worten mit den worten
schwarze null als fetisch machten sie
augenscheinlich wahrscheinlich die idee
dass die bürgerinnen und bürger einsetzt
sind aber ich kann nicht sagen ich habe
viel fanpost bekommt erste schwarze null
als fetisch richtig die bürger hat mir
zugestimmt zweitens haben sie gesagt
endlich meine frau mit der ordentlichen
roten lederjacke und drittens kann man
die linke auch in bayern wählen das kann
ich bestätigen
ich bedanke mich für diese werbung für
meine partei und nicht und verzichte
ausdrücklich auf ein honorar vielen dank
sie können nicht nur noch die redezeit
darauf antworten liebe kolleginnen
vielen dank auch für diesen werbeblock
das video richtungsentscheidung kann man
sehen auf csu die herzlichen dank dafür
aber es geht ja um mehr als diese eine
richtungsentscheidung wie sie
angesprochen haben nämlich über die
frage ob wir unendlich neuverschuldung
machen oder ob wir zur schwarzen null
stehen es geht auch darum ob familien
weiter entlastet werden oder ob sie
belastet werden spd grüne und linke
wollen das ehegattensplitting abschaffen
und wer das ehegattensplitting
abgeschafft der macht doch nichts
anderes als dass er für millionen von
familien die steuer erhöhen das ist das
ergebnis dieser entscheidung
ja vgb hat er vor kurzem dazu gesagt das
trifft ja nur
alleinverdiener familien erstens falsch
und zweitens was für sie nur ist das ist
für uns die mitte der gesellschaft dog
dister gehen
ihr parteivorsitzender übrigens norbert
walter borjans sagt dazu dass die
abschaffung des ehegattensplittings ja
nur die reichen trifft ich sage ihnen 80
prozent der familien die vom
ehegattensplitting profitieren haben ein
familieneinkommen das unter 60.000 euro
im jahr ist und das sind für sie die
reichen für mich ist das die mitte der
gesellschaft und die gehört belastet und
nicht belasten meine damen und herren
und übrigens auf eine frage einer jungen
familie mit zwei einkommen mit drei
kindern wie diese familie den mehr von
ihrem einkommen haben kann wie mehr
übrig bleiben kann vom einkommen hat
vorletzte woche eine gegenfrage gestellt
nämlich ob denn schon sozialleistungen
beantragt werden ist dass ernsthaft ihre
vorstellung von sozialer gerechtigkeit
steuervorteile wegnehmen unter für
sozialleistungen anbieten ich sage ihnen
wir wollen etwas anderes das
ehegattensplitting erhalten den kinder
vorteil ausweiten und alleinerziehende
mit 5000 euro pro jahr entlasten das ist
unser modell
und wir wollen deutschland fit machen
für die zukunft
jaja bundesfinanzminister zur
wettbewerb wettbewerbsfähigen wirtschaft
da gehören auch wettbewerbsfähige
unternehmenssteuern
entlastungen für unternehmen sind für
sie bundesfinanzminister weltliches
zitat ein absurder einfach stattdessen
wollen sie erbschaftsteuern erhöhen
vermögenssteuer einführen da gibt es
auch in der regel sehr viel applaus von
der ganz linken seite aber ich will
ihnen auch deutlich sagen mit diesen
ideen werden sie nicht das vermögen
besteuern sie werden im mittelstand bei
familienbetrieben bei der landwirtschaft
die substanz besteuern und das zerstört
investitionen und innovationen und das
führt am schluss nicht zu mehr
beschäftigung sondern zur
arbeitslosigkeit das ist das ergebnis
und dabei haben sie heute wieder von
respekt gesprochen dieser respekt gilt
offensichtlich nicht für den deutschen
mittelstand wir haben hier vorhin
pauschal unterstellt dass diese
unternehmen riesige gewinne machen sehr
geehrte finanzminister es wäre besser
gewesen sie hätten hier erwähnt wie
viele in den letzten monaten auf ihre
rücklagen auf ihre ersparnisse
zurückgreifen mussten dass menschen
nicht riesige gewinne macht
familienunternehmen nicht riesige
gewinnen machen sondern dass sie große
risiken eingehen mussten eigenes kapital
in die hand genommen haben und
unternehmen und arbeitsplätze zu
schützen und die brauchen entlastungen
und keine belastungen von ihnen
und wir müssen diese diskussion
über die souveränität führen
souveränität von deutschland und europa
wir haben in der panini doch mehr als
deutlich festgestellt dass die
globalisierung zähler die globalisierung
hat ihre fehler gezeigt als masken und
schutzausrüstung gefehlt haben als
medikamente knapp geworden sind jetzt
gerade sehen wir das in deutschland
automobil bänder stillstehen weil
konnten für computerchips nicht
ausreichend zur verfügung stehen und
deswegen brauchen wir auch in
deutschland und europa eine
souveränitäts offensive ja produkte auch
wieder in deutschland und europa er
stellt das ist keine absage an einen
freien welthandel im gegenteil das ist
das bekenntnis zu einem freien enthalte
aber auf augenhöhe und wir brauchen
deswegen eine bereitschaft uns nicht
dauerhaft einseitig von einer einzigen
region in der welt abhängig zu machen
[Applaus]
er wurde mehrfach darüber gesprochen
dass deutschland ein industrieland
bleiben soll
ich würde das auch ich will aber auch
dass deutschland ein automobil land und
wir erleben gerade den start der iaa der
internationalen automobilausstellung und
wir erleben gerade auch wie die
aggression gegen dieses automobil gegen
diese internationale ausstellung auf den
straßen in brennt wir erleben gerade wie
sogenannte aktivisten autobahnen
blockieren sich von autobahnbrücken
abseilen wie sie gerade sich und
verkehrsteilnehmer in gefahr bringen und
es wäre schön wenn die grünen an der
stelle doch mal deutlich auch sagen
würden haben diese aktivisten in
deutschland die jetzt wieder gefahr auf
unsere straßen bringen die gegen das
automobil sind haben die irre
unterstützung oder distanzieren sie sich
endlich von so einem vorgehen
wir stehen zum
automobilstandort deutschland
dazu gehört auch dass wir
spitzentechnologie nicht einfach
aufgeben
jaja dubiel industries im wandel ja das
ist der weg auch hin zu
elektromobilität aber es hängen auch
viele viele arbeitsplätze vom
verbrennungsmotor ab und der
verbrennungsmotor ist deutscher
hochtechnologie und ich will nicht dass
wir hochtechnologie in deutschland
einfach aufgeben ja die batterie
galactic ist ein weg aber es ist nicht
der einzigste weg wir brauchen auch die
synthetischen kraftstoffe ich will dass
der verbrennungsmotor co2 frei weiter
betrieben wird und arbeitsplätze draytek
in deutschland sichert meine damen und
herren
und übrigens gilt das gleiche auch für
die luftfahrtindustrie
in einer schwierigen situation braucht
auch genau diese industrie
zukunftsperspektive und jetzt sagen die
grünen sie wollen die kurzstrecken
überflüssig machen aber was sie damit
tun ist dass sie die mobilität in europa
einschränken werden europa ist aber
nicht nur ein freiheits versprechen
europa ist auch ein mobilitäts
versprechen die menschen wollen in
europa zusammenkommen und europa wird
zusammengeführt weil die menschen
zusammenkommen und dafür braucht es die
schnelle mobilität und wenn sie diese
schnelle mobilität unterbinden dann
unter finden sie das zusammenwachsen
europas und das ist kein profi schlag
das ass gegen europa gerichtet und wäre
die innovation bei fliegen nicht
durchsetzen will ist das völlig
abschaffen er beginnt gegen europäische
anti europäischen markt bei den damen
und das klima spielt eine große rolle in
dieser ganzen diskussion ja ich bin dass
er dafür
ambition und akzeptanz genau darum geht
es bei uns ambition und akzeptanz beides
muss möglich sein wenn wir über
klimaschutz reden man rettet das klima
nicht wenn man das gesellschaftliche
klima vergiftet und ja deutschland muss
vorreiter beim klimaschutz sein deswegen
haben wir diese wahlperiode
auch die co2 bepreisung für mobilität
und für wärme beschlossen ja aber
gleichzeitig haben wir beschlossen wenn
der co2 preis steigt dann sinken auch
der strompreis wenn der co2 preis steigt
dann steigt die pendlerpauschale wenn
der co2 preis steigt da wird die
umrüstung der ölheizung auf erneuerbare
billiger das nennt man umsteuert das ist
unser weg an der stelle immer mit
entlastungen gepard sehr geehrte
verwirrt wenn ich ihnen zuhört wenn sie
über das energie geld reden da reden sie
doch von etwas grundlegenden anders sie
machen nichts anderes was dass der co2
preis der geht an der zapfsäule raus
dann geben sie einen 75 euro gutschein
an die menschen den man an der
tankstelle wieder ein das ist doch kein
umsteuert das ist im kreis drehen weil
die damen und herren
ja doch aber sie können sehr gerne mal
konkretisieren mit ihnen jetzt aufgeht
dass das ganze keinen sinn macht was ihr
an dieser stelle erzählen aber seinen
jahren zugestanden
sie sind die ökologische linke in diesem
haus alles okay uns geht es um
ambitionen und anreize gleichermaßen und
deswegen sind wir die ökologische mitte
in diesem haus war die damen und herren
und der scholz
noch eine abschließende frage an der
stelle wären sie eigentlich bereit ihren
satz zu wiederholen den sie vor einiger
zeit hier gesagt haben bezüglich dem
ikone wiederaufbau vor nämlich dass er
der notwendige einstieg in eine
dauerhafte fiskalunion ist es wäre
interessant zu wissen weil diese
fiskalunion herr scholz das ist nichts
anderes als die schulden
vergemeinschaftung die haftungsunion die
schulden union in europa unter will ich
ihnen dann der stelle erklären es gibt
einen unterschied ob man in einer
krisenhaften situation seinen ängsten
nachbarn in europa unterstützt oder ob
man für eine dauerhafte schulden
vergemeinschaftung ist wir leben denen
die schulden und die in europa ab
dankeschön
[Applaus]